former president trump's legal team
turned the tables laying out their
arguments against impeachment
and forget the brevity in a few concrete
ways they dismantled
key pieces of the democrats rather
incoherent constitutional arguments
i'm going to break down a few pieces
tonight for you the most important ones
number one the core claim of democrats
impeachment article
is that trump's speech incited the
january 6 riot his speech on january 6th
but here's trump counsel michael
vanderveen
the senate should be extremely careful
about the president
the precedent this case will set
consider the language that the house
impeachment article
alleges to constitute incitement
if you don't fight like hell you're not
going to have a country anymore
this is ordinary political rhetoric that
is virtually
indistinguishable from the language that
has been used
by people across the political spectrum
for
hundreds of years
and he had the examples
democrats are going to fight like hell
we fight like hell
i'm going to fight like hell we're going
to fight like hell i and i know many of
the senators and members of the house
will fight like hell we are going to
fight like hell
we're going to fight like how fight like
hell
well it's language that they've used
that republicans have used big deal
shows nothing
number two remember house impeachment
managers tried to make the case
that trump's alleged incitement is based
on things
he said months beforehand even though
that's not in the article
now attorney david shone responded with
this rather inconvenient fact
democratic candidates can claim that an
election was stolen because of
russian collusion or without any
explanation at all
and that is perfectly okay and is in no
way
incitement to an insurrection and
somehow
when democratic candidates publicly
decry an election as stolen
or illegitimate it's never a big lie
you've been doing it for years
of course we we documented it we covered
it night after night after night trump
was
never a legitimate president to any of
them from hillary on down
number three last night we showed you
how head impeachment manager jamie
raskin himself tried to block the 2016
election results
well today the trump team exposed
raskin's co-conspirators
i object to the votes from the state of
wisconsin which would not should not be
legally sent
i object to the certificate from the
state of georgia i object to a
certificate
from the state of north carolina i
object to the certificate from the state
of alabama the electors were not
lawfully certified
are they all guilty too they don't like
democracy
no they had a problem with a
certification so they made their
statements and they said their piece so
by the democrats own standard
all of those sound bites all those
comments in some way
constitute altogether something
approaching
sedition the traitors
of course that's what they want you to
believe that's the bogus threshold
for incitement that they offered against
president trump
but when they use that same language
they openly question the legitimacy
of a presidential election they add the
whole russia collusion onto it with zero
evidence
it's totally innocuous and in fact it's
constitutionally protected speech
and finally the attorney van der veen
succinctly exposed the democrats
constitutional overreach
the house manager's position as stated
in their trial brief
is and i quote
the first amendment does not apply at
all to an impeachment proceeding the
text of the first amendment
expressly restricts congress from
regulating speech
the position advanced by the house
managers is essentially
an unlimited impeachment standard
without constitutional
guard rails unmoored to any specific
legal test other than the unbridled
discretion of congress
but it's certainly the intent of the
democrats well political revenge was and
is their main motivation when it comes
to the former president